-The President is still
holding the government hostage
over its demands
for a border wall
as federal employees prepare to
go another week without pay.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We are now in day 34
of the government shutdown,
and the consequences
are very real.
More than 800,000 federal
workers are missing paychecks.
The basic everyday functions
of the government
are grinding to a halt.
Even the eagle
in the presidential seal
is currently unemployed.
There are also the crucial
day-to-day functions
that no one thinks of, the
things we all take for granted
that are essentially
at a standstill
thanks to Trump's shutdown.
-800,000 federal workers
on the verge of missing
another paycheck,
workers who,
just like the rest of us,
they have to
feed their families,
they have to pay their rent.
Airports especially hard-hit
right now
with 10% of TSA screeners
calling in sick
and air-traffic controllers
warning planes will just
sit on the ground.
-Critical government services
are also deteriorating.
Food safety inspections
have been curtailed.
The FBI and federal agents
are seeing their cases hampered,
according to an article
in "The Washington Post."
There's been a slowdown
in planning
for hurricanes
and other disasters.
-Think about that.
The Trump administration
will now be even less prepared
for hurricanes
than they were during this
briefing in the Oval Office.
-I've received a briefing
from Secretary Nielsen,
Administrator Long,
and my senior staff
regarding Hurricane Florence.
They haven't seen anything
like what's coming at us
in 25, 30 years, maybe ever.
It's tremendously big
and tremendously wet.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean, at least...
at least he had two charts
next to him.
I mean, could you imagine
what those charts will say
if there's a hurricane
during the shutdown?
"If I can direct
your attention to 'big.'"
All of this is happening for one
reason and only one reason --
Trump's demands that we pay
billions for a border wall
that he repeatedly said
Mexico would pay for.
And Trump's argument
is simple -- walls work.
For example, in the places
where they already exist,
Trump claims walls have had
an immediate impact.
In talking to reporters
this week,
he named one city in particular
where a border wall
is making everyone safer.
-Everybody knows
that walls work.
You look at different places,
they put up a wall, no problem.
You look at San Antonio.
You look at so many
different places.
They go from one of the most
unsafe cities in the country
to one of the safest cities
immediately.
-There you go.
The proof is in San Antonio.
They have a border wall,
and it works.
There's just one problem.
San Antonio is 150 miles
away from the border.
Either...
Either he is confusing it
with San Diego
or he's just putting walls
in random cities now.
"Walls work, folks.
Just take New York City.
We put one
around the M&M's store,
and it's keeping out
the Times Square Spider-Man."
Trump is the one who said
he'd be proud
to shut down the government,
and yet after House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi told Trump
yesterday that she would
postpone the State of the Union
until the shutdown is over,
Trump blamed her.
-We were planning on doing
a really, very important speech
in front of the House
and the Senate,
the Supreme Court,
and everybody else that's there.
It's called
the State of the Union.
It's in the Constitution.
We're supposed to be doing it,
and now Nancy Pelosi --
or Nancy, as I call her...
-Oh.
You call her Nancy.
Good burn.
You're so good with nicknames.
I guess that's why
they call you...
Donald.
If Trump was your roommate,
he'd label his milk
by writing "milk" on it.
If he was any less creative,
this would be the name
of his building.
[ Laughter ]
Trump then went on to explain
that he thinks he knows why
Pelosi canceled the speech.
-The State of the Union speech
has been canceled
by Nancy Pelosi
because she doesn't want
to hear the truth.
-Dude, you don't even know
the truth about
where San Antonio is.
You're afraid of the truth
and maps.
"We built the wall in San
Antonio, folks. It's beautiful.
Unfortunately, we did have to
build it on top of San Antonio's
most famous landmark,
the Golden Gate Bridge."
[ Laughter ]
And not only is the shutdown
paralyzing basic services
people depend on
and subjecting federal workers
to needless suffering,
it's undercutting
Trump's stated goal
of securing the border.
For example,
the FBI says the shutdown
is hurting its ability
to fight MS-13,
which is crazy because Trump is
obsessed with gangs like MS-13
which he falsely claims
are pouring into the country
over the Southern border.
Sometimes he even spins
elaborate fantasies
about towns
that are occupied by MS-13
and liberated
by law enforcement.
-You know, it's like liberating.
Like, a war.
Like there's a foreign invasion.
And they occupy your country,
and then you get them out
through whatever.
And they call it liberation.
You're liberated.
And these towns
are being liberated,
and the people are clapping.
They get them,
they take them out,
and the people
are in their windows.
They're clapping and screaming,
and they're happy.
-They're clapping and screaming,
and they're happy?
Did he accidentally watch
the end of "Return of the Jedi"
and think it was the news?
"And let me tell you.
The little bears,
they're the happiest of all.
They're screaming and clapping
and doing their little dance.
And one of them said something.
It made a lot of sense to me.
'Yub nub.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, it's not surprising
that Trump lied about the wall
or that he's detached
from the reality
of what's actually happening
on the border.
It seems like every week,
we get a new insider account
about just how unfit he is
for the job
and how chaotic the
White House is as a result.
The latest account is a tell-all
book called "Team of Vipers"
by former White House director
of message strategy Cliff Sims.
Sims describes a president
who's uninterested
in the basic duties of his job
like a meeting with former
House Speaker Paul Ryan
about the GOP
legislative agenda.
-In early 2017, the Speaker
comes up to the White House
with Mike Pence,
the vice president,
to explain how tax reform
is going to work
in all of its wonderful,
mechanistic detail.
This does not interest
the President very much.
And after the conversation's
gone on for a while,
he literally gets up
while Paul Ryan
is in mid-description
and wanders
out of the Oval Office
and down the hallway
into a side room
where one can hear the
television being switched on.
And eventually,
Mike Pence gets up,
goes down the hall,
brings the President back,
and they finish
the conversation.
-Oh, my God.
We have a president who
just wanders around the house
in slow motion no matter
what's going on around him.
It's like we elected a Roomba.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, that's very interesting.
Yeah. No. That's really cool.
That's really cool."
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump was also easily distracted
by random obsessions.
For example, he was preparing
for a televised call
to the International
Space Station.
He was getting ready
for the call.
Trump suddenly appeared
distracted, distant.
As the clock ticked down,
Trump suddenly turned toward
the NASA administrator.
He asked,
"What's our plan for Mars?"
The administrator
explained to the President
that NASA plans to send a rover
to Mars in 2020
and by the 2030s would attempt
a manned space flight.
Trump bristled. He asked,
"But is there any way
we could do it by the end
of my first term?"
Why? Are you trying
to escape somewhere
that's out of Robert Mueller's
jurisdiction?
"Mr. President...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mr. President, we have
a warrant for your arrest."
"Oh, yeah? Well, you'll
have to catch me first."
The story actually
gets weirder, though.
Trump was still distracted
with just minutes to go
before the live televised call
with the space station.
As he walked with Sims from the
dining room to the Oval Office,
he decided to stop
in his white-marble bathroom
for one final check
in the mirror.
He had 30 seconds before
he was supposed to be on camera.
In the bathroom mirror, Trump
smirked and said to himself,
"Space station,
this is your president."
Is he turning into a terrible
David Bowie cover band?
Of course,
none of this is surprising.
We could only guess what kind
of politician Trump would be,
but we knew what kind of
employer he would be --
a [bleep] one.
And he's not even the only
[bleep] boss in the White House.
For example, today one of the
billionaires in Trump's cabinet,
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross,
was asked about
the 800,000 federal workers
going without pay
during the shutdown
and said he couldn't
understand why they
don't just take out loans.
And, again, remember,
this man is a billionaire.
-There are reports
there are some federal workers
who are going to
homeless shelters to get food.
-I know they are, and I don't
really quite understand why
because, as I mentioned before,
they --
the obligations
that they would undertake,
say borrowing from a bank
or a credit union,
are, in effect,
federally guaranteed.
So the 30 days of pay
that some people will be out,
there's no real reason
why they shouldn't be able
to get a loan against it.
-Never take financial advice
from someone who appears
next to a stock ticker.
He does not have
your best interests at heart.
"Now if you'll excuse me,
my riches!"
[ Laughter ]
The government is paralyzed
by a petulant president
subjecting millions of people
to needless suffering
for a wall that won't even work.
Polls have shown that public
opinion is firmly against him
and firmly on the side
of Nancy Pelosi, or...
-Nancy, as I call her.
-This has been "A Closer Look."